good morning everybody or good afternoon
or good evening thanks for joining us
here at this latest edition of our
social media marketing webinar series
with Jennifer kario social media ma with
2016 drawing to a close pardon me
marketers are getting ready to revamp
their strategies for the coming year so
Jen's here with her thoughts on what
you're gonna want to focus on next this
isn't asking me anything style Q&A
webinar it's a great chance to get input
on all things social media for the
coming year so hopefully you've got some
questions in the back of your mind to
ask Jen she's gonna do a short
presentation and then we'll get to the
questions if you're not familiar with
who Jennifer kario is of course I can't
imagine why that would be but let me
take care of that she is the president
of sugar spoon marketing a highly
respected international speaker and
trainer at industry conferences and by
invitation to corporations around the
world she has served as adjunct
professor for Rutgers University's
online social media mini MBA program and
is the author of three books including
Pinterest marketing an hour a day before
we get rolling I just want to give you a
quick sense of how this is going to work
and what to expect so as I said Jen's
gonna do a short presentation about
upcoming trends and things you should be
a have your eyes open for it's going to
run maybe 15 or 20 minutes and then
we'll get into as many of your questions
as we possibly can you're going to send
us your questions through the question
module so let's just just to make sure
that check and make sure that's working
right now find the little question
module if you would in your dashboard a
little field there says ask a question
and I think is how its labeled go ahead
and say hi to Jen let her know how
you're doing you're looking forward to
hearing what she's got to say let us
know where you're joining us from be
curious to know where folks are joining
us from today I know we usually get
folks from all around the globe and I
see Lindsay's here from Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania fantastic have never been
but I understand
a great place to visit if not live I see
Angela is in Washington State Jessica's
here from Maryland Doug's here my ankh
is here from Rishikesh in the fantastic
round the other side of the globe phase
her from Vancouver
Rikers Island and Cathy's here and
wishes a happy holiday to everybody
alright this is great this means that
the audio is obviously working you're
hearing me I'm not just speaking into
the void of GoToWebinar and we use that
questions module all you want during the
presentation and after to pose questions
about any of the things Jen top spot or
about anything that she didn't talk
about that you want to ask with regard
to social media trends moving into 2017
if you've got a personal challenge with
one of your campaigns or something you
want to get a little insight into maybe
the best next step Jen might be able to
address that for you too
so I think that's all you need to hear
from me
without further ado return your seats
and tray tables to a full and upright
position observe the no-smoking sign
remember no flash photography I'm gonna
put myself on mute Jen I won't let you
take over
all right well chip I'll tell you right
now that when we come to the Q&A if
Lindsey has a question she goes to the
front of the line yeah I'm just down the
way from you in Washington County so not
too far away at all another line go
Pittsburgh
okay so launching into this I don't know
about the rest of you I'm bettin chip
agrees with me on this one if you're
anything like me you cannot wait to say
goodbye to 2016 and you're so and here
to be done with this year now on the
social front there were definitely some
interesting things that that happened
but I think all of us are really looking
forward you know on the whole to see
what the new years going to bring us so
before we kind of dive into that and
some of the predictions coming from the
industry and sort of what my personal
thoughts are on those I want to do a
little bit of looking back because there
were some pretty significant changes to
the social media landscape some of which
were kind of new and introductions and
some of which were
sort of the tipping point where we saw
some ideas that had been introduced
earlier really start to become sort of
mainstream so one of the big ones was
definitely the push in to live video
while live video launched a couple years
ago through periscope and you know on
Twitter and some other places it was
really when Facebook decided to push
Facebook live out to everyone not just
businesses but to everyone and I don't
know if you've noticed the TV
commercials popping up now that
apparently we're all supposed to live
broadcast our Thanksgiving dinner or you
know our birthday parties that's the big
push and in general if Facebook decides
to adopt something and push it you're
gonna see some pretty good adoption
points coming into play um interesting
thing to note is they actually just
announced yesterday that the launch was
coming for live 360 video in fact
National Geographic is going to be the
the beta test today at 3 p.m. Eastern
Time so if you're interested in checking
out to see what live 360 degree videos
gonna look like on Facebook National
Geographic will be broadcasting the crew
members coming out of the Mars desert
Research Station facility they've been
in there for 80 days and it'll be the
first time that they've kind of come out
and had contact with everyone again so
this will be interesting to see because
obviously you know live is getting
pushed but we know that that that 360
view especially with sort of augmented
reality and virtual reality coming into
play you know we know that that's gonna
be something that's that there's a big
push for this year also with Facebook
having sort of the the API in place that
allows you to broadcast your live feed
through a third-party video you know it
doesn't just have to be from your phone
obviously that's gonna open up the door
I would guess for both the 360 and the
180 cameras for people to be able to
broadcast the video feed through those
so maybe you're not necessarily doing a
full 360 because not everyone has that
capability but you know Nikon's got a
little camera now for I think about
three hundred and fifty dollars that
does some pretty incredible 4k quality
180 degree video streaming or video
recording so you know things like that I
think we'll see come into the in
mix another thing that happened this
last year is Instagram kind of took a
shot across the bow at snapchat or snap
as it's now becoming called Instagram
still tops the chart as a millennial
favorite and that's something important
to remember even for all the
conversation we've had about snapchat
and if you were on last month's webinar
you heard we kind of covered what was
going on with snapchat marketing now
Instagram still at the top but snapchat
was kind of nipping at its heels and
we'd seen a lot of growth in snapchat of
course with Facebook owning Instagram
you know there's a little bit more power
and a little more money back there to do
some development so with Instagram
launching stories and Instagram and
snapchat sort of going head to head is
that sort of real-time up-to-the-minute
live feed of what's going on in your
life and your ability to broadcast out
those curated stories that the change
over time because everything drops off
of that 24 hour window that's one of the
big changes that we did see pop up this
last year was kind of that idea that
instead of having a ready-made upfront
sort of fully screened story or video or
article or infographic that there's a
little bit more of a real-time feed and
again between stories and the live video
on Facebook we're really starting to see
things trend in that direction of how
can you actively engage people so they
feel like they're actually part of maybe
the decision-making or what's going to
happen next or that their experience
discovery at the same time as other
people so that's a big change that we
really kind of seek um really kind of
saw coming to the mainstream this past
year another big one fake news that was
definitely a massive massive issue this
past year sites like Snopes no longer
enough to fight off that barrage of fake
news and even just propaganda we know
with the with the brexit vote with the
US elections and even all sorts of
things mixed in between there was a lot
of issues with some of these sites
popping up that just blatantly it's not
even you know spin it's not even
different perspective but just blatantly
reporting absolutely fake news
mobile is another big one again mobile
has been a player for years but I think
this year is gonna be the one that kind
of goes on the tipping point level where
everybody really started to fully
embrace it a lot of the people coming on
social media even for the first time in
a lot of the emerging markets they don't
have desktop access the only access they
have into the social world is via a
mobile device or you know a tablet or a
handheld device so that's definitely
something where we're going to start to
see that shift and how people are
spending a greater majority of their
time accessing social media is a lot
more of it's going to come through
handheld devices rather than desktop
units or you know solid stable units and
with Google really kind of shifting
around their algorithm to put an
increased focus on mobile and mobile
capabilities I think this really becomes
the year we're moving forward we have to
accept that Mobile is no longer a second
thought it's no longer and also has much
like social media has become a fully
integrated part of marketing in general
mobile has become a fully integrated
part of how people can expect to engage
with our brands and with our content
another big one that kind of ties back a
little bit
you know we've long touted the ability
of like-minded people to come together
and share information you know share
thoughts share resources that you know
influencers sort of arise within
different groups that have the ability
to really sway public opinion but I
think this last election and then again
the brexit vote really shined that light
on the reality of social media echo
chambers and how easy it is for people
to have an inaccurate perception of
global views or even regional views
based on the limited connection points
that they have because with all of the
algorithms coming in place on you know
Facebook and Twitter and you know even
Instagram is going to be having one come
in here before too long and Pinterest
there's been this goal to make sure
we're showing people content that they
like well generally the content people
like is the content that they tend to
already agree with or believe in and so
that's really kind of created some
challenges in social media and I think
it's one of the big truths that came out
this year that we need to look at moving
forward is what it means to understand
that people sort of have their their
social connections predefined now again
there's new people coming online and
there's always gonna be some growth but
social media has kind of been here long
enough that people have settled in and
they're comfortable with who they
connect with and with the environments
that they're interacting in and that
doesn't always leave a lot of space for
new ideas or new perspectives or new
thoughts to come into play so clearly on
a societal or a political spectrum that
presents its challenges but we also have
to recognize that that's going to impact
us on the marketing side when we're
trying to get into markets when we're
trying to share new features you know
when we're trying to kind of jump some
of those gaps to say hey wait you might
not know about us but you know let's get
into the mix there another big one
that's a it's actually gonna be on the
list for 2017 of what we'll be talking
about is augmented reality and virtual
reality really kind of stepping up this
year I think Pokemon go well it sort of
had its big spike in the initial fervor
has kind of died down a little bit the
thing that it taught us for 2016 is that
the door really is open to creative
applique
patience for both augmented reality and
virtual reality and that people are
excited and happy and interested in
engaging with things in that type of
environment and so I think with a lot of
the technology that's going on and again
I'm going to touch on those here a
little bit later and I'm hoping that
that takes up some of the discussion we
have today because I'm really excited
about some of the augmented reality
applications for social media but this
was really kind of the test it and prove
it and hey yeah this is gonna work so
what can we develop and how can we get
it implemented another big area that we
saw a lot of a lot of growth and a lot
of kind of eye-opening in 2016 was an
increased interest in more private
social communication so clearly we know
that people have their public facing
networks you know who you connect with
on LinkedIn or Facebook or even Twitter
but the growth of snapchat and whatsapp
and facebook Messenger we see a lot of
consumers turning their backs on that
public facing social media for some
types of messaging in favor of direct
messaging again knowing that it's
broadcasting to a smaller or more select
group of people which lets you feel more
comfortable being open about you maybe
the non curated version of your life and
so one of the things that we've started
to see pop up with that as well is
clearly there's going to be a need for
businesses to understand how to engage
in those ways and to figure out where we
can break in versus where it's going to
be not just disruptive marketing but but
interruptive and angering marketing to
try and get into the mix there so with
all of that said it's kind of the
question is what does the future hold
for social media again some years we see
more change than others so part of the
question is is 2017 gonna be one of
those game-changing years and I think on
the virtual reality and augmented
reality front I think we definitely have
the potential to see that happen and
also within the messaging space I think
there's a lot of room to see that happen
or is it going to be a year that's maybe
a little more focused on reasonable
growth and taking the time to kind of
refine some things so let's take a look
at some of what the big predictions
coming out across social media channels
I kind of spent some time going through
the roundup see any all the different
sites that have put out their
predictions for next year and kind of
trying to aggregate it together to see
what the biggies were linked
what my thoughts were on it so one of
the first one is the idea that social
media channels are going to attempt to
become a vacuum where everything you
want to need is contained within so the
example that I keep giving people and
chip you've heard me say this a million
times Facebook wants to be America
online they want to be the place that
you connect to the moment you get on the
internet that you do all your messaging
that you do your shopping your browsing
your news reading that everything's
happening within Facebook and we're
seeing more attempts from Facebook we're
seeing more attempts from LinkedIn we'll
be seeing some more stuff come out from
Twitter to get companies to put their
full content within these realm this as
opposed to kind of the teaser content
and then linking into the full content
on your website so that's one of the
huge predictions now personally I say
you need to resist this now we know
Facebook and LinkedIn
are pushing it but giving in entirely
and just saying okay fine this is gonna
be my presence online it's a mistake I'm
telling you it's a mistake don't do it
at best choose some forms of content or
some versions of your content and go
ahead and publish them take advantage of
those new platforms that are coming out
by all means be publishing some content
straight into Facebook be publishing
some long-form content straight into
LinkedIn but you have to make sure that
anything you're putting out on social
media has the ability to tie back in to
your site to get that traffic and to get
those links in to get those that
conversion experience the trackability
make sure you keep the best stuff on
your site yeah I'm not saying don't
participate at all but I'm saying from a
marketing perspective and from the
limited ability to kind of police and
care for and value and measure
everything that goes on on a third-party
site it is a mistake to just give up the
ghost on everything that you've created
for yourself all right the second one
social media world says messaging public
facing channels will still be important
but in 2017 the massive growth is going
to start happening happening with
messaging apps and BOTS very similar to
what we see with email marketing but
with a little bit more of a real-time or
interactive perspective I say I
completely agree as
one-to-one communication starts to shift
from email to messaging and we kind of
thought shift from email to text so
obviously a lot of companies have kind
of shifted gears and I'm sure I'm not
the only person who has plenty of text
messages come in with this discount or
this special offer or this deal that's
happening we're gonna see a lot of that
start to shift in messaging as well in
fact keep in mind that there's a lot of
places where SMS messages are charged
per message you know not every country
has unlimited text messaging like a lot
of us have here in the United States
that's a big reason why a lot of these
messaging programs like whatsapp in mine
and you know we chat why they're doing
so well so you need to make sure that as
people start to not fully abandon email
but is a lot of that conversation shifts
out of you know it's going to be
important to at least give people the
option to connect with you that way I
don't know how many of you might chop
off the mobile app wish but wish does
pretty much all of the customer service
interactions via Facebook messaging now
and on a pretty regular basis I'll get a
ping on messenger and it's you know
here's the new offer here's the reminder
of what's going on or here's a special
code and with a lot of the apps and the
bots that are now available to be
integrated with Facebook messaging I
think we're gonna continue to see a lot
of growth there okay the next one social
media world says storytelling now
clearly storytelling is sort of already
cracked the mainstream but the general
consensus is we're going to continue to
see more growth and more focus on
leveraging storytelling within social
media I say I agree with the
introduction are not the introduction
but sort of the tipping point of live
video with the curated story feeds
popping up on Instagram popping up on
snapchat honestly I wouldn't be
surprised if we see something similar
start to pop up or at least get tested
on Twitter or Facebook both of which it
would make sense to have them come into
the mix I think that idea of irrelevant
interactive narrative taking place with
consumers that has a lot of potential
and I think it's something that really
needs to be in the back of your mind
coming into this next year is if you're
not playing with any of those tactics
now it's a very good idea to say okay
what would it look like for us to do
this what can we test it with you know
what makes sense for us to you know
go in what sort where's our target
market ad because if your target market
is not hanging out on snapchat and
Instagram right now then something like
Facebook life is gonna make a lot more
sense to you if you're targeting
Millennials you're definitely going to
want to look a little bit more it's
something like snapchat or Instagram all
right the next one social media world
says and this has been a big topic in
the last month policing whether we're
talking about fake news cyberbullying on
Twitter or hacking into accounts expect
to see more and more call for a policed
and regulated Internet now again this
one gets really tough because if
someone's gonna police it who's gonna do
it the most part it would have to fall
back on the channels themselves to
figure out what their policies would
look like and what they put in place
clearly Twitter and Facebook are both
testing some of these options right now
as are some of the others but that idea
of something where you know human being
is deciding what's right to go in and
what's not that leads me to say balance
because anytime policing gets involved
the people with the most power get to
define what is and is not okay so this
is a fine line for channels to walk and
I'm gonna be very curious to kind of
watch and observe and see what this
looks like because well it's not
something that I think directly impacts
our marketing right now or what we're
necessarily going to do next year it is
going to have an evii impact on the tone
and sort of the the atmosphere in the
environment that takes place in some of
these channels as well as with the
people who are there because again if
you see a specific viewpoint or mindset
really starting to dominate on a
specific channel and other viewpoints
are cracked down on you're gonna see a
whole groundswell of people leaving
looking for someplace else to go
where those viewpoints are more accepted
so I think there's some interesting risk
and potential involved with this idea
and this is one that I just kind of
encourage us all to kind of keep an eye
on okay another one social media world
says virtual reality and augmented
reality are the next big stage in social
media evolution that it will be the
integration of virtual and augmented
reality on existing channels and on new
channels I say absolutely this is the
one that I absolutely agree with the
most that
most excited about I cannot stress
enough how OnPoint I think this is for
the future of the social media industry
particularly in the augmented reality
world and that's one of those places
where I think I do vary a little bit
from sort of some of the general
industry consensus is right now
everyone's talking about virtual reality
because Facebook has purchased oculus
and has started to you know really some
samples and some videos of what it would
look like to sort of interact in
Facebook but in that virtual reality
world where you're sort of you know
representatively showing up and
connecting and what they view is a
face-to-face connection I think there's
potential there I think we're a little
bit further out from really seeing price
points come down enough to really make
that applicable
I think the augmented reality on the
other side there's a lot more things
there right now that I think can more
easily be adapted via you know phone
apps that don't necessarily require the
more expensive virtual reality headsets
and units and I think we're going to be
able to see AR come into place a lot
more quickly a couple quick examples on
these and then I'm wrapping up and ready
for QA one if we're again if we're
looking at AR integration I'm really
excited about the idea of social social
media tagged content being overlaid on
physical locations so for example if I
have geo tagged something in facebook
you know because maybe I've checked into
a location maybe I have written a review
on Yelp I would love the concept of an
app that integrates that on my phone so
that I might be able to hold my phone up
and ski on a street you know in downtown
New York City because I'm looking for a
restaurant and actually see that overlay
of hey you know chip Street has done a
review on Yelp of this location you know
Matt McGee did a review of Yelp on this
location so being able to physically see
some of that social media content in
that real world environment shared
virtual experiences which with your
social connections that one's clearly
going to fall in a little bit more than
virtual reality side they are overlays
and physical locations tied to online
deals or ads now what I mean with this
is opposed to sort of that social media
tagged content is let's see if you're in
the US or Canada
and you shop at Target and you use their
cartwheel app if you go into your
cartwheel app you can pick an item you
can tell them what store they're in and
they will put a visual map up and tell
you exactly what aisle it shows on so
you know you can say okay well I just
need to go you know up into the left and
do such-and-such I think what we're
gonna start to see in some of those apps
is that ARR overlay where you're holding
your phone up in front of you and you're
actually actively looking at the aisle
and we're gonna see those arrows pop up
you know think of the colored arrows
that show up on the floor sometimes in
hospital to lead you to you know the ICU
versus the CVU versus you know the NICU
I think we're gonna see some of that
come into play with phones where we've
got more ability to again get that
visual overlay I think of you know
Pokemon go and the fact that you could
see the character you know sitting right
in front of you through your phone of
course you take your phone away and it's
not there I think some of that level of
interaction is going to be a big part of
what shows up is marketing opportunity
this coming year and then finally don't
cannot microsoft hololens and off-site
on-site engagement if you haven't done
much viewing of some of the videos that
show up on youtube both for the virtual
reality like through oculus or through
Playstations virtual reality headset or
if you haven't gone and checked out
microsoft hololens take a look at it
because some of the application there
things like the real estate companies
that are mapping out entire houses and
so you can go and put the hololens in
and you can go to one location and
actually physically walk through like 10
houses in the span of an hour so you
know you could be in New York and you
could be checking out 10 different
houses in San Francisco a lot of the
hololens capability is kind of tie into
some of the virtual reality but there's
a lot of augmented reality options with
it where we're not kind of closing out
the world around us we're simply
overlaying something on top of what
we're already dealing with and I think
you're gonna see a higher comfort level
from consumers in engaging with that
type of environment as opposed to
something where once you put that mask
on you literally someone could walk up
in front of you and punch you in the
face and you wouldn't know they were
there so I think we'll see easier
adoption coming in on the AR side
alright so Jeff that's the
kind of all I've got for here so I'm
looking to hear thoughts and where
people are thinking of expanding or what
other trends or predictions they've
heard or whatever the heck we want to
talk about yeah so this is finally gonna
be the year of mobile I heard you say so
we'd let Jeff Passan know that this year
is finally the year that 2016 was the
year of mobile I'd like to think
Mobile's done and not done but you know
they they have they're shining light
let's focus on something more fun like a
VR and you know say okay yeah everyone
needs mobile we know that I said that he
might not agree he's been saying it's
the year of mobile for about four or
five years now so we'll see we'll see
how that pans out before we get to the
questions and we do have a couple I'm
gonna go ahead and take care of what I
like to call my my contractually
obligated poll moment here I'm going to
take 60 seconds to just throw this poll
up on the screen for folks webinars of
course is just a little part of what we
do here at market motive it's a perk for
our members and we do seven or eight of
these every month across a variety of
disciplines we do content marketing we
do SEO PPC and mobile and obviously
social media and we make these available
to the public now as sort of a service
to the community we love to do that
share the insights of our SMEs with
everybody and that's terrific but it is
not all that we do this is public facing
so you may or may not otherwise be
familiar with the other things that
market motive is involved in our core
services that we are a training
publisher we create web-based digital
marketing training curricula that are
used by higher education institutions
like Duke University and Rutgers their
courses are licensed by agencies and
professional organizations they're used
by in-house Enterprise teams to bring
new hires on board more quickly make
them more effective more quickly get the
teams all speaking the same language and
kind of get out of those silos by
cross-training folks across these
various disciplines these are structured
courses with streaming videos
downloadable workbooks quizzes tests
exercises can apply them to your real
world challenges and
and put the knowledge that you're
gaining to work right away you also get
access to moderated forums you can
interact directly with the faculty and
other students you can ask questions
about the materials you can get a little
guidance on how to apply the lessons to
what your real-world marketing
challenges might be so you know if you
want to know more there's no obligation
but take the appropriate box somebody
will get in touch with you give you a
backstage tour maybe help you figure out
which membership level or which course
is the appropriate one for you to focus
on so that you can meet your personal or
your business goals and they'll be happy
to help like I said no obligation but
you'll get a free tour we've already got
your email because it's attached to your
registration information here on
GoToWebinar so someone will get ahold of
you by email if you want a fast-track it
a little bit and you'd rather have
somebody call you you can just drop your
phone number into the question module
will be this today but it'll be attached
to your profile all right
I'm always appreciative of you indulging
me for that 60 seconds I'm going to
close this now so thanks for putting up
with me and we should go back to Jen
screen here GoToWebinar is a little
pokey today about catching up there we
are we're on the wrap-up now so yes we
do have some questions in the system
here so first off
Courtney is asked saying and asking the
launch of Instagram stories definitely
shook up content planning for a lot of
this year if a stories type feature is
added to even more social media
platforms in the coming year do you
think it would be best to diversify the
content on the various channels or
should you recycle your stories content
and just redisplay it on various storey
enabled platforms oh that's a fantastic
question good job I think it's a
combination of both
I think there's times where it makes
sense to broadcast kind of the the
duplicate message or the same thing out
across to other channels but we also
need to kind of be aware of what the
tone and the mindset and the interaction
style is on different
and I think you also need to be careful
that what you're putting out sort of
matches that so for example we we did a
workshop and it was this within this
last year chip probably remembers better
than I do where we talked about taking
one piece of content and kind of
formatting it and having it ready to go
out into different channels you know
what does it look like to put it on
Facebook if you want to get engagement
and shares and interaction how do you
put it out on Twitter because maybe on
Twitter you might be sharing it you know
10 times over the span of a week with a
lot of different lead ins you know how
do you put it on Pinterest well again
Pinterest may have several versions with
several different images in several
different calls to action you know
there's different environments there
that story concept because it's similar
across the board I think there needs to
be some measure of exclusivity in some
of the content otherwise there's not
really a reason for people to follow you
in more than one place so if the
majority of people are following you say
on Facebook right now and face book
launches stories but you also want to
pull that millennial audience in on
Instagram or on snapchat you know
clearly you're going to need to have
some content that's only going out to
snapchat or Instagram so you can give
people that reason to come over and
engage with you there there's also a far
less formal sort of format and style of
what goes on to snapchat in particular
and I think that same level or style of
content on Facebook would not play
anywhere near as well you know that
makes that makes total sense the demos
are so different across some of these I
have absolutely no interest in snapchat
myself I'm just way too unless I'm
trying to spy on my kids hopefully
Courtney that answered your question is
sort of a follow up from Lindsay which
is along the same vein which is just you
know presume is also necessary to create
unique content between say Facebook and
LinkedIn disregarding the stories aspect
or do you think it's sufficient to just
share this content on either one of
those two channels and link it back to
your blog again some content it's fine
to go ahead and sort of put the teaser
out there but if you're going to look at
in
aging with sort of the long-form
long-form content that shows up on these
channels so like you know Facebook
allows you to publish content directly
into Facebook now and you know they'll
even you know insert your ads and other
stuff into it as does LinkedIn LinkedIn
pulse has actually shown that people on
that particular site they like longer
content something that's around 1,200
1,500 words that tends to be the sweet
spot on LinkedIn but if you try to
publish a piece of content of that
length on Facebook you wouldn't get the
same reception so I'd encourage you to
do a little digging on what some of
those optimum sizes are again there's
plenty of companies out there that do
you know millions millions of a be split
tests and then release their results to
the public for the rest of us to use
checking out some of that sometimes it's
just a different format you know maybe
you're putting a summarized version on
Facebook and maybe you're putting the
full form content on LinkedIn it's
knowing what the audiences absolutely
that makes perfect sense yeah I'm
HootSuite and buffer are two places that
do a great job of sharing the results of
their they've got just such immense data
on this because they're not just using
their own data but they're using the
data of all their users you know to sort
of see what engagement is like on
different kinds of content on different
channels so looking at HootSuite and at
buffer app calm or to great places to
see yes thank you yeah all three of them
are very generous with their data yeah
awesome awesome okay let's say Doug is
asking how do you see marketing
advertising playing out in the AR and VR
sphere okay that's a great question I
mean our we're just going to see sort of
billboards appearing in front of us on
through our wearables as we're walking
down the street what do you see the
short and long term on that look Jen did
we lose you oh dear I fear we may have
lost Jen all right
okay now there we go now you're back all
right I thought you vanished but I
vanished sorry about that
okay I think I caught most of that so
you were asking about the marketing and
advertising sort of tie in with in an AR
in a VR world and what that might look
like yeah shorten long term what do you
think that's going to evolve like okay I
think short term it's gonna be a little
simpler I think short term we're gonna
see some we're gonna see some fun apps
come out that you know maybe they're
games like Pokemon go and it's going to
be sort of this simple inserted
advertising where you know maybe I'm
walking around in that augmented reality
world hunting for you know Pikachu and a
Santa hat because that just came out
this week and maybe you have the ability
to overlay a billboard with your message
you know so I'm out hunting but I'm
still seeing your marketing message
maybe I can click on it within the app
and we'll take me over to your website I
think that's going to be the simplest
easiest starting point that we're gonna
see but I think as some of these options
become more sophisticated that's where
we're gonna open the door into some of
these experiences so again maybe maybe
that means that there's a you know open
table or Yelp or someone like that adds
an overlay that's a paid option for
businesses where again I hold my phone
up and I'm scanning the street and maybe
if you've paid that access fee the name
of your restaurant is gonna show up you
know tied you and there's gonna be a
link to view your menu you know so I can
quickly based on that geographical
location jump straight into some of that
data I think we're gonna see some of
those pop up and then like I mentioned
with target and cartwheel you know the
ability to maybe walk into you know the
gap or Macy's or someplace like that and
click something in my email that they've
sent me that's a discount and it's gonna
put the arrows on the floor in front of
me to take me directly to that item in
the store so I don't have to hunt for it
I think that's going to be the first in
easiest applications we're gonna see pop
up on the marketing side
that's such a science fiction world I'm
just imagining it at the same time but
Minority Report is that where Tom Cruise
like walks past a gap and yeah and
they're trying to sell him a sweater to
go to khakis he bought last week because
they scanned his eyeballs exactly it's
cool and it's creepy and it's also
incredibly lazy because I'm trying to
imagine you know like I'm standing at
the end of the block and it's like wow
walk three doors down and look at their
menu in the window I want to stand in
one place and span the street it would
be great if it also of course
incorporated something like you know how
many open tables are available right now
or at least this is a peak time of the
day you know as other times of the day
because otherwise I still need to walk
down the street and just kind of check
it out like do I like the look and feel
of the place it's super crowded it's
really noisy there may not be things
that we get in that overlay but it's
it's pretty it's pretty fascinating
nevertheless well and you know let's
let's turn the before we go to the next
question let's turn the tables on that
real quick and let's look at some of
that downside because that's we tend to
get really excited about you know
options and what's popping up and like
with Pokemon go you know everyone kind
of got excited because people got out
and got physically active right because
you had to walk to play the game
in that environment now when we're at
PubCon this year Robert Scoble gave the
keynote and he was talking about
microsoft hololens and you know some of
the virtual reality options and one of
the things that he said everyone got
really excited about and I'm sitting
back there and I feel like I probably
had this look of horror on my face going
how is anyone not seeing the other side
of this because what he said was that
the virtual reality that they're
actually because of how it impacts your
brain they're using it for pain
management techniques with athletes
because it can help you know the same
way that what are those those little
things that like you attached to the
nodes and you know it makes the muscles
vibrate or whatever oh yeah yeah you
know attends unit yeah the TENS units
can help with pain relief that this also
does and then the thing that he said
that made me go oh wait what
is that the virtual reality interface
was more effective than morphine at
managing pain which is cool on one front
but also make you say okay but
morphine's addictive and so wouldn't
that mean that a virtual reality
environment is also more addictive than
morphine is and we know what's happened
to people with their smartphones in the
last decade so what's that going to mean
on the virtual reality and even
augmented reality front like you said
it's that laziness it's cool technology
but do we then you know what does that
do societally that's a whole other
ethics issue but I just have to throw
that out there for people to think about
I think that's my fault I started that
talking about how lazy people are but
yeah you how many science fiction
stories have we read that take place has
some sort of dystopic future where
people are sitting in chairs you know
and and not against their own freewill
like in the matrix by design like in
wall-e or you know I forget what the
series is I think it's burning Chrome
maybe I think it's Bill Gibson maybe
talks about Stimson's and people being
plugged in and just kind of lost forever
in their little virtual world not
wanting to come out so long range who
knows it's a little scary
but in the short term you know seeing
the overlays let's let's just focus on
marketing aspect of it it feels like
augmented reality in the short term is
still going to be through and this goes
a little bit to something Lindsay's
sorry FA is asking which is do you see
Google glasses or other kinds of
wearables like that coming back because
of the opportunities in augmented
reality for marketing as well as just
interacting with you know the
environment around you and it feels a
little bit like until that happens most
of the AR is still gonna be through a
handheld device where you have to make
the decision hold your phone up so it's
not going to be in terms of marketing
necessarily interruption marketing right
you know suddenly
a billboard appears in front of your
face as you're walking down the street
the way we saw in Minority Report you'll
still be making the decision at this
moment I want to hold up my phone and
look around me right and keep in mind it
it starts as a decision but it's not do
you really make the decision to pull
your phone out to get directions to
someplace or is it just so intrinsic to
you now that it's not really a conscious
decision it's just what you do exactly
so I think on the on the AR side I think
the marketing and sort of the even some
of the social interaction how we see
those tie-ins taking place I think we're
gonna see it limited or not limited but
predominantly taking place through a
phone for probably at least the next
year if not maybe two or three because
the issue with things like Google glass
and microsoft hololens which from what I
can see you know not having had a chance
to use hololens because they're not
really if you know out there yet it's
only some specific press that have had a
chance to play with them
it looks like hololens really does a
great job of accomplishing what Google
glass set out to accomplish now does
that mean Google will circle back around
and try and redevelop to you know kind
of match or be on par with well you know
Google's not really gonna get left
behind by Microsoft right so I would
imagine we'll see something there and
even when we look at snapchat putting
the snap spectacles together that will
now you know record whatever you're
looking at and automatically feed it
into your phone so that you can be
taking that live video you know from
your glasses and you know adding that to
your your snap story I think we're going
to see some integration into the
headsets like that but the biggest issue
right now is is going to be cost right
you know cell phones have smartphones
have finally reached the point where
they're affordable for almost everybody
and until we see that tipping point of
the technology that's found in something
like a hololens or something like you
know the Google glass being affordable
you know till it comes down low enough
that it's affordable I think we're gonna
see most of it restricted to phone so I
think we're several years away from
reaching that point and of course by the
time we reach that point they're already
going to have some you know in
or other thing put in place where you're
not really wearing glasses right but
you're still getting it projected and
it'll be contact lenses or whatever else
at the risk of keeping us talking about
this as opposed to moving on to the next
question I'm just going to ask you and
anyone else out there if you've watched
Black Mirror on Netflix you should yeah
black mirror is a science fiction series
that is essentially like a what's the
word I'm looking for it's it's not a
continuing storyline from from one to
the next it's a collection of short
stories sort of so there's no continuing
character from one to the next
but it all takes place in this
alternative future where all the things
that we're talking about right now are
kind of meshed with the idea of the Tom
Cruise movie and whatnot where folks
have these lenses in their eyes and a
little implant behind their ear and
everywhere they look they can look at
someone facial recognition tells them
what that person's score is and where
they work and history is and so forth
and it's also surrounded by advertising
constantly so if you want to get a
little snapshot of what it's going to
look like that's Louise Lewis is saying
black bear is pretty good highly
recommended to any technologist and
marketers most especially so yeah
definitely something as marketers we
Lewton we need to look at not every
episode is great but it's it's really
fascinating stuff so Fay yeah we think
Google Glasses or something like that
are gonna work their way back in but
they're not going to be meaningful until
there really is affordable and all right
so let's see my aunt has a general
question what's your views on organic
versus paid social media marketing I
think we have to accept the fact that
organic brand driven social media
marketing has now reached a point where
it is exceedingly difficult and thus for
a lot of companies it is far more
realistic to expect to have a
combination of paid and organic
because really you're paying for it
either way you're either paying in the
development costs in the management
costs of putting together consistently
amazing organic content to be able to
maintain that push or you're balancing
it with targeted advertising and because
the advertising options are so laser
targeted and focused and like audiences
and you know remarketing and everything
else I think it's just realistic for
people to expect to have a combination I
think the free right part of social
media is over and that's not necessarily
a bad thing sorry I was still on mute
alright perfect I hope that gives you a
little bit of insight into what you were
looking for there
andrew is asking when will a Facebook
have a are built into the capability of
the platform so that developers can
build native apps well I was I was
watching yesterday from when Facebook
did their there oculus conference and
Mark Zuckerberg did you know like a live
demo on like from the stage where he was
he connected with the Oh his first name
is Michael but I can't remember his last
name the guy within Facebook who's kind
of leading the charge on what they're
doing with virtual reality and kind of
took us through a tour of different
things what did it look like to have
three people gathered and you know to
play cards and then suddenly you know
someone whips out a lightsaber and
instead their sword fighting and you
know then hey let's go take a tour of
Paris and now we're walking through
Paris and we're actually taking you know
a photo of ourselves standing in front
of the Eiffel Tower and publishing it
straight to our social media channel you
know Facebook has that environment
created for internal testing purposes
and they've started to show it off a
little bit you can definitely go to
youtube and look up some of the videos
and you can really see what it looks
like at play but they haven't yet
announced any dates of when they expect
things to begin to launch or to begin to
come become accessible my guess is that
it won't necessarily come online and be
accessible to us in 2017 but that by the
end of 2017 we'll have that we'll have
the dates you know like we'll have some
type of projected expectation and we'll
also know what types of
sort of software it will work with is it
only going to work with oculus and
Facebook and bought it or would you be
able to use you know your your hololens
or your you know playstation set up or
heck i have i don't know if you've seen
that the google cardboard you know can
you use the google cardboard thing that
you slot your phone into and use that
for your you know virtual reality world
there's there's a lot of tie in that has
to come in to really be able to have
them give us dates so i don't expect it
next year again that's why I'm saying I
think a are is gonna be the thing that
we really see a lot of a lot more actual
hey we can access this and use this now
technology pop up in 2017 and I think
virtual reality is still going to be a
little further down there other than
that that makes good sense it's
interesting to hear though how how
Facebook is you know moving forward with
this and and their time to market on
these things it's really pretty stunning
and in the overall when you think of it
overall in the old days how long was it
before we finally got to proper LCD flat
screens you know and now now and they
were out of out of reach for so many
people price-wise and they just seemed
so so what's the word I'm looking for
like a luxury you know and and and now
who has the CRT anymore right I mean
everything is flat screen and it took 10
years maybe to go from one to everybody
having you HD and 4k it's not going to
take that long for these other things to
come online because I think that
population is more hungry for the new
content or the new technology and
Facebook and Google and Microsoft just
have you know all the money in the world
and all the resources in the world to
just really push these things through
their development well and consider the
multiple applications you know in a
world where you're using a hololens
hololens as it is right now will project
the equivalent of 130 inch screen onto
the wall in front of you so you can
watch you know any window or video or
whatever it'll do 4k video so why do i
need you know we've we've got a 90 inch
screen and you know full surround sound
you know in the
and everything set up in our basement we
have a theater in our basement what do
we need that for if I can put on my
hololens and you know I've still got all
of the sound quality and I can project a
hundred and thirty inches and Matt could
sit on the couch next to me with his the
hololens and watch a completely
different movie
you know we're snuggled up but we're
watching two different shows both in the
same size on the same screen in front of
us but there's not actually a TV on the
wall that's that comes back to that
whole thing of like are you are you
really sharing the experience that's a
whole social element of it right it's
like are you really saying the
experience though because you're
watching a tearjerker rom-com and he's
watching you know alien versus Predator
I said I was thinking you know Steelers
versus Ravens at nighttime yeah except
you you have that wrong he was he
watches the tearful romantic movies and
I watched the action movies but but yeah
there's a social aspect to that are you
really sharing the experience or not no
she's not gonna separate us more but
nevertheless yeah I I agree I mean we're
sort of there now
with multi screens right because I hang
out with us stop playing video games
come in the living room hang out with us
let's watch else great and he comes in
and he spends half the time we're
looking at his phone runs and doing
other things while the rest of us were
watching the movie and I feel like he's
not participating into him
that's totally know this is how you
participate yes because that's what he
does when he hangs out with his friends
what are you talking about I just texted
you this this mean didn't you see it oh
my goodness all right let's see Lindsey
is asking is there social planning and
publishing tool that you think is best
obviously there are lots and lots of
tools out there and there's more than
one best but do you have any that you
recommend for planning and publishing a
calendar 12
hello calendar tool honestly we I've
played with a bunch of them I do
I like sprout social I'm a fan of sprout
social but when it comes to actual
calendar planning I'm old school we have
a whiteboard and post-it notes and you
know we use color-coded post-it notes
and move ideas around and figure out
what things are gonna look like and then
everything gets put into basically a
Google Doc that's shared with the client
and we track everything through that I
haven't found anything I like enough
that I would push the whole process into
it there is there's a new one that I
just stumbled across oh and I can't
maybe someone will remember what it is
the logo looks like sort of a cartoon
octopus and it's similar in concept to
something like buffer but when you
create your content you put it in and
you can tag it by topic but you can also
tag it by type of content so like is it
an infographic is it you know a short
burst video like you might use on
Instagram or is it a longer form video
like you might use on you know Facebook
and it creates an archive for you and
then what it will do is it will auto
populate to fill the space in your
calendar from stuff you've used in the
past so you're kind of being a
refreshing content so you can say look
we're talking about you know augmented
reality right now so if I've written any
articles on Pokemon go if I have videos
on Pokemon go slot that in for the week
and it will go pull out of it and it's
killing me that I can't remember the
name of it maybe chip might be able to
find it but it's new it's just starting
to come online and it looked like it had
a lot of potential it's one of the few
that I've seen in the last six months or
so where I went okay I actually kind of
want to get in and play with that
because I think that idea of having sort
of that cataloged database that you can
pull into Auto feel or autofill you know
your content calendar with some maybe
evergreen content I like that for
functionality standpoint that sounds
fabulous I love that I'm not familiar
with it I'm doing a quick search but I
don't want to make everybody wait while
I'm digging around I see one called
spread fast I'm in a text Matt while
we're talking on the next question and
see if he knows what it is all right
well let's see we will
move from there to my young this is a
great question about which social media
platform to focus on which social media
platform in 2017 will be best in terms
of getting more traffic to our blog
obviously that's going to depend a lot
on who your audience is targeted to your
audience yeah the one where your
audience is and where you can best
present your content again it's there's
not any one answer even even today
Facebook is not the be-all end-all
answer every everyone for the most part
needs to have a presence there but it's
not going to be the best platform you
know for oh that the little sour patch
kids yeah for sour patch kids they have
done amazing things on snapchat and you
know brands like Tiffany's and Jenny's
ice cream and Columbus Ohio they've done
amazing things with Instagram and you
know other brands are doing amazing
things with Pinterest if it's going to
be the one where you have the strongest
ability as a company to get in and
connect with your target audience and
there isn't anyone be all when all yeah
that's it really is exactly that just
different audiences different
demographics are gonna live on different
platforms so you're just going to have
to do the homework to sort of figure out
which one is best for you and then you
know experiment with different kinds of
content to see what kinds of content get
people to click and come back you know
to your home base she said that's he was
saying that's what his real goal is is
to generate traffic back to the website
so do people do a better job of that
with video infographics teasers or
social stories or what yeah I got to
interrupt you for one second it's meat
Edgar calm meat the site Edgar EDG AR so
if you want to type that into the window
and make sure people have access to it
put in for an for an invitation to get
in now but they do have some information
up on the site where you can kind of
look at how it works um you said calm
yeah meat Edgar calm
I just shared that into the chat window
folks so you can take a look at that I
also had earlier put the link in for
sprout social failures asking if you
have maybe a one minute two minute
summary
I liked that sprout social hat and
honestly sprout social has a lot of the
same features as everyone else I just
physically and visually liked the
environment they had I like the ability
to go in and assign something to a team
member for follow up so for example I
could go in and look at all the
conversation that was taking place on
say Twitter and Pinterest and a blog
Channel and someplace else about a
particular clients and then if it had to
do with you know a piece of content I
could assign that to someone on my team
to go and respond to but if it had to do
with maybe a question about you know
billing or customer service or something
like that I could assign it to someone
on the clients team and put it straight
into them and I could go back and very
easily check to make sure people had
followed up and actually you know done
what they were supposed to do so in
terms of sort of management I really
liked it on that side publishing wise I
didn't find it to be particularly
different from you know HootSuite or
buffer any of the other options that
published but I liked the way it managed
teams and the interactions and allowed
you to kind of assign and follow the
history of what was going on that's
that's pretty cool I know that HootSuite
for quite some time has had a team's
tool like that but you had to pay more
to get more team members attached to
your profile to your account and the
interface was and always has been really
clunky with HootSuite and kind of a high
learning curve to to really become a
power user but I've used those those
assignment kinds of features in
HootSuite and even with their clunky
interface found it to be pretty powerful
so it's if it's wrapped up in a tool
that has a better social but it's also
more expensive I think sprout social
starts around $100 a month depend
many team members you have but again for
you know for a midsize client or for a
midsize company you know if your little
teeny tiny company you know nickel and
diming at that's that's not gonna work
but if you've got some budget to work
with I found it to be a really nice tool
for working with teams good to know yes
okay so that's sprout social
and then we're but up at the end of the
hour I have one if you have an extra
minute this is this is not a one-minute
question but I don't want to leave
Monica hanging so she's got a somewhat
of a general question that maybe we can
at least give her some guidance as to
where to go look for this information
and the question is how do we determine
where our target audience is on social
media yeah that's a good question okay
so there's a couple things one when it
breaks down demographically so for
example if you know you target
Millennials if you know your target you
know people with aging parents if you've
got some type of demographic info a lot
of times just going out and searching
you know 2016 or now going into 2017
social media demographic data you can
get the demographic profiles that are
sort of the overall profiles for the
different channels to see ok older
people tend to skew here younger people
tend to skew here when it comes down to
topically you have to go in and actually
spend some time in the channel running
some searches for conversations Twitter
in my opinion is the easiest place to do
this to go type in some keywords and see
what people are talking about on
Instagram it's a little easier to go in
and you know kind of make use of some of
the hashtags to look for conversations
see what people are talking about
snapchat gets a little harder because
snapchat makes discovery
really difficult it's one of the reasons
that I think the Malena millennial
audience has really kind of migrated
towards it is they like a little more
feeling of privacy and non interruption
you know people have to choose more to
engage with you so that one is probably
a little more asking around doing some
general market research and you know
maybe kind of yeah that sounds harder
with Facebook again you can get some of
the demographic data and you can you
do some testing which is really nice but
remember a lot of facebook conversation
is not publicly accessible because of
people's privacy settings so the
recommended approach from me for
Facebook is to actually go in and set up
some small budget level you know even if
it's just 50 bucks some targeting for
the interests the age the demographic
and check to see what type of response
you get at least look to see how many
views you get and what the potential
reaches outside of that a lot of it is
just taking some time to kind of play
around and ask around and test to see
what happens
think that maybe Monica if you have an
existing email list to of people that
opted in to do an upload of a what they
call it a custom audience in Facebook
Twitter will do that right now Facebook
does that and Pinterest also does that
where you can upload your existing
customer list and it will go through an
automatch any accounts on that social
channel that use that email list now
again it's not going to be foolproof
because someone like me you know I've
got like eight email addresses and the
one that I use on Facebook I it's not
even one of my everyday emails it's what
I used way back then so it's not always
gonna be a hundred percent accurate but
I think the last day - I saw her
Facebook in particular was that it picks
up about 60 to 70 percent
Masha's is what it tends to translate
into and as long as you end up with at
least a thousand matches then you can
create a custom audience out of that and
you know kind of market to your existing
contact list within the context of that
particular Channel cool cool cool all
right Monica I hope that helps and I'm
gonna that's actually the last question
we've got in the queue and it's and
we're at 1034 so we have used our time I
could keep talking about this though
this is where we're the direction of
social is going to go over the next few
years
pretty darn fascinating so maybe you and
I'll just get together sometime soon and
keep this conversation some coffee and
we'll brainstorm all the all the AR
opportunities that's going to pop up
that will fix it and will will let
everybody know what the future looks
like all right well thank you so much
Jen always fun to hang out here with you
and thank you to everybody else who
joined us from all around the globe we
appreciate you taking time out of your
day and and cutting loose to hang out
here with us I hope you got something
out of it and please do feel free to
join us for future webinars so there are
lots of them queued up but both at the
market motive site and at simply learn
calm you can find future webinars
they're not only in social digital
marketing but in social media but across
a lot of different topics so lots and
lots of webinars out there and take
advantage of we hope you join us here
again soon until then thanks everybody
we appreciate it
have a terrific rest of your day take
care bye bye
you